good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight so if you've been
watching the news you've got to give
some credit to whichever msnbc
contributor wrote the word to that joe
biden speech earlier
if you didn't know better if you had no
context you might
think everything is better now the great
orange emergency is finally over it's
1996 again and we can exhale
our democratic norms are on their way
back out of russian cold storage
last month's election was a win for all
of us quote
in this battle for the soul of america
joe biden just told us
democracy prevailed so it wasn't a
partisan exercise it certainly wasn't
theft it was a victory for you
personally
in america biden's speechwriter wrote
politicians don't take power the people
grant it to them so thanks for the
civics lesson joe biden
joe biden wants you to know he didn't
run for president three times because he
craves power
or because he seeks to enrich his
near-to-well relatives or because he has
a
vast empty space inside that only the
adulation of strangers can fill
no not at all he ran for president
because he deeply cares about you
joe biden is a paternal figure really
you might even call him the father of
this nation
of course that would make kamala harris
america's permanent stepmother
which doesn't quite have the same
reassuring ring to it but whatever
details are not important right now
what matters joe biden wants you to know
is that this is a democracy
always has been always will be and by
electing biden and the small secretive
group of billionaires who choreograph
his every move
this country has become even more
democratic small c democratic of course
and that's reassuring to hear honestly
because some of us were starting to get
other impressions non-democratic ones
just the other day for example bill
gates announced that the lockdowns we're
enduring are going to have to continue
for a long long time
now keep in mind bill gates is not an
epidemiologist he's not a research
scientist either
bill gates is a retired 65 year old from
seattle who used to make mediocre
software
for office computers but now he's a
billionaire
therefore bill gates gets to decide our
national health policy
pretty much the same way retired hedge
fund operator tom steyer
gets to tell you what to think about the
weather or how 78
year old mike bloomberg decides which
guns you can buy
or how george soros can choose your
prosecutors or how tim cook of apple
runs our trade policy
or how mark zuckerberg of facebook can
keep america's borders open just because
he feels like it but nobody says
anything because his friend fellow
billionaire jeff bezos owns
washington dc's hometown newspaper and
may soon buy cnn
that is the democracy joe biden is
talking about the kind of democracy in
which 11 left-wing billionaires who fund
his campaigns run
everything that's the chinese model of
democracy that joe biden and his friends
so admire
so get used to it america it's a new
kind of democracy
in china people in power don't have to
answer questions
so neither does joe biden just last year
a voter brought up the biden family's
corruption during a town hall event and
joe biden responded
by calling the man fat and challenging
him to a push-up contest just like the
chinese do
just this friday an op-ed in the wall
street journal pointed out that joe
biden's wife
dr jill biden isn't actually a real
doctor sorry she's not going to be
treating your high blood pressure
dr jill biden has the very same degree
as dr bill cosby does
which is one degree from dr pepper but
joe biden and his friends didn't want to
hear that
we'll tell you how they've how they've
responded in just a moment
but before we do we have some actual
journalism to report tonight
on friday a reporter with this network
peter ducey tried to get
joe biden to address a factual issue
his son hunter biden is now under
federal criminal investigation relating
to
tax fraud stemming from his business
deals in china
so here's how the conversation went did
hunter
find it commit a crime
have you spoken to your son mr president
i am proud of my son said joe biden if
that sounds familiar there's a reason
that's the same rehearsed non-sequitur
that the
biden harris transition team sent out in
a press release last week and you're not
getting any more information than that
just a minute ago we heard about how in
america politicians don't take power the
people grant it to them
but it turns out the people granting
that power don't get answers
what we do know is that joe biden is
very proud of his son
and his son's federal criminal
investigation and that's all you need to
know
so why isn't joe biden willing to answer
even basic
questions about his son's foreign
business dealings
the ones where he had lucrative
arrangements very lucrative arrangements
with companies directly tied to the
communist party of china
well possibly it's because joe biden
himself was directly
involved in those deals and has been
lying about them
we've been telling you that for more
than a month and now it's obvious
one of hundred biden's former business
partners tony babalinsky already
presented contemporaneous documentation
proving that the reason the press corps
and their allies in silicon valley did
everything they could to bury that story
is that they knew perfectly well that
more evidence was coming
and it's arrived that's evidence that
they can't
suppress this weekend the daily caller
obtained
new evidence emails from hunter biden
here's one september 2017
hunter biden wrote to his building
manager in georgetown in washington dc
and he wrote this quote
please have keys made available for new
office mates colin
joe biden jill biden jim biden the
brother
gong wang dong chairman of cfsfc
emissary oh
so the new office mates included the
former vice president his
doctor wife and gong wang dong
representing
cefc the chinese energy company
according to emails published by the new
york post
was reserving a 10 equity stake for joe
biden
the man that gong wen dong represented
cefc's chairman yi
has ties to the chinese military and
intelligence services apparently he's
since disappeared somewhere in mainland
china
but according to an august 2017 email
written by hunter biden chairman yee
also offered hunter biden a three-year
30 million dollar contract for quote
introductions alone to whom you know
whom
his dad joe biden
as we said germany has since disappeared
apparently he's been arrested by chinese
authorities
if all this seems a little dodgy to you
not quite a straightforward business
deal
you should know that back in 2019 joe
biden wasn't repeating the same line
about being proud of his son
no he went on the record and denied he
knew
anything about his son's business
relationships abroad including with
chinese communists
the very same relationships that were
slated to make him
rich i have never discussed with my son
or my brother or anyone else anything
having to do with their businesses
period i've never discussed it said joe
biden it never
came up even in the office with gong
wang dong and
dr jill biden we talked about sports
and how proud joe biden was of his son
the one under
federal criminal investigation the truth
is
joe biden must think people are as slow
as he's become
this isn't even a solid cover the point
of the biden political operation one of
them anyway from the very beginning
has been to make as much money influence
peddling
as possible so if you're wondering how
joe biden who's been in public office
since 1972
that's just the federal level almost 50
years how has joe biden been able to
live in 10 000 square foot homes almost
the entire time
a number of them how do you do that on a
government salary
how did hunter biden go from
unemployable to rich virtually
overnight well you know the answer
they haven't even tried to hide it back
in january 2017 a man called eric
sherwin he was then the president of
hunter biden's company which is called
rosemont seneca
wrote to hunter biden to warn him that
things were getting a little too
obvious here's a quote from the email in
2014 you joined the barisma board in
ukraine
and we still need to amend your 2014 tax
returns to reflect the unreported
barisma income
that is approximately four hundred
thousand dollars extra so your income in
was closer to one million two hundred
and forty seven thousand three hundred
twenty eight dollars
end quote now we don't know because
we're not the irs
whether hunter biden ever amended his
tax returns to account for the hundreds
of thousands of dollars he was making
from ukrainian oligarchs
in a business that his father made
possible by firing the prosecutor
who was going to hurt the company that
was paying hunter biden
we're not making any of this up we're
not into conspiracy theories
that's all true and it unfolded in
public
the doj's investigation presumably is
looking into all of that
but the emails from eric sherwin do
offer another window into the kind of
life
the bidens were living here's his email
to hunter biden
since you couldn't have lived on
approximately five hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year sherwin
wrote to hunter biden you quote borrowed
some money from rosemont seneca
in advance of those payments so here you
have hunter biden
the son of joe biden who is himself a
son of scranton pennsylvania son of a
coal miner
took amtrak to work every day
this is a person who became so dependent
on peddling influence
that he couldn't live on a 550 000
a year salary this is the person
joe and dr jill biden are proud of
the rest of us and this is not a
personal attack it's just true
if you're going to restore democracy the
rest of us have a right to know exactly
where the money came from
what did they do for it and what effect
is it going to have on the country going
forward
in a democracy that's a very basic
request
and there's nothing democratic about
ignoring the question
in fact it just confirms what's obvious
which is they don't plan
to govern this as a democracy but
instead is an oligarchy